hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Treasure
Island the first Early's first that I
know of fangame of five nights at
freddy's now even the developer said
that he didn't expect this to get that
much attention but he should have known
considering he made a game about five
nights at freddy's so this one is disney
inspired there is Mickey there's goofy
there's Donald now everyone in the world
who was trying to get me to play this
and I was like does the world really
need more five nights at Freddy's but
you guys demanded it so here it is I
will try to play this bistec hey buddy
its Greg here
hi Greg hey uh so sorry again for making
you do this you are an intern after all
yeah but we're so over here in Alabama
getting our equipment ready before we
head off to where you are we are
professionals so we need to keep track
of our stuff so we don't look stupid
anyway though so if you're familiar with
a layer of the place then you've
probably heard of the photo- Miki
costume that wanders around no thing is
though you look like someone who doesn't
care you just want to let your time run
out and get your credits but if you do
care then listen up that thing from what
we heard it can only hear you can't see
anything so that means if he wanders
into your office then shut off one of
your cameras I know it's not straight so
if you make a rad sound that will lure
the suit out of your office you may have
a small window of opportunity to react
so be quick about it
alright I'll leave it up to you oh and
by the way don't screw up any of our
equipment Oh wouldn't want to screw up
Greg's equipment now would we
oh this lovely place where dreams come
true
Disney incarnate everything is happy and
fun here great thanks Greg you're a
douche okay so from what I see there's
something here some pair of legs
sticking out from behind
that box I bet they thought that I
wouldn't notice but I'm very in tune
with boxes as you all know I wonder if
that's like Donald's but because his
head is just kind of here for some
reason with black eyes and then the
photo negative Nikki Nikki that walked
around photo negative Nikki is something
completely different
and then there's Goofy's head which I'm
assuming that his eyes will open at some
point there there's a meat cleaver here
there's something there and the whole
place is lit by these ancient from the
first time Disney opened incandescent
bulbs so I wonder why I'm here I wonder
why I need to be here but I do like
creepypastas and there's a lot of really
good Disney related creepypasta so I'll
see what happens I mean who knows I mean
obviously it's not gonna compare to the
real five nights at Freddy's but it is
made by one guy one fan he has actually
done not about job of recreating it not
that the game is entirely complex by
itself it's a bunch of static images
that are pre-rendered but still I mean
from what I'm seeing it's not that
terrible I don't know what's happening I
don't know why it's happening I don't
know what I need to do in relation to it
but oh wait no oh oh oh hi oh okay ah
shut off cam shutoff cams out okay I did
it I don't know what the hell happened
he was just kinda standing there I kind
of wanted to talk to him Oh what the
[ __ ] we why is his head off wait a
minute back up a second here I reacted
oh it's probably cuz I accidentally put
up the camera again before he got there
okay did not expect that I'm sorry
everybody as I was saying before I oh
come on I don't to listen to you again
ragged dick okay zom back into the game
now my mistake is because this is a
little finicky kinda wants to double go
up if I don't do it very gingerly so
that was my problem I think engineering
is the reason why I died there totally
unexpected it had a jump-scare to it but
then again I got the volume packed up
and I don't know what's going on I mean
that's what made the original five
nights at freddys very scary is that had
an air of mystery I honestly had no idea
what to expect both when I first started
playing the first one in the second one
once I got into it I sorta had a
predictability of what was going on now
there are some different mechanics here
that I'm not fully customized with so I
got a press base to shut off the cams
when they get in the room and I gotta
make sure that when I do drop the cam
that I quickly see react do and go so
but I don't know is if Goofy and Donald
are also going to be problematic to it
because as you know who Goofy and Donald
are the most sinister creatures in the
Disney universe oh yes
goofy will have his evil laugh and
Donald will quack is evil quack and then
Mickey will wander in and orchestrate
all the demise and desecration they will
lay waste upon your very soul so beware
young ward
beware the Disney world is a world of
wonder but it also is a world of danger
and death see when I lose my voice for
some reason must be when they lose their
voice they get like raspy and can't talk
but when I lose my voice I lose my upper
register so I can I can't
upper register very well but I gain the
base e basest of base I am all about
that bass about that bass about that
bass no treble I'm all about that bass
about that bass
that base notre oh he's got okay wait
he's not here yet didn't wander into
another area uh yes he is kind of cool
because I can oh wait okay so he's not
in here yet so I need to quickly react
shut off one of my cameras he does get
in here is he gonna be like hiding in
the shadows who am i always gonna notice
when he's here where you go I don't know
why shutting off a camera would cause a
loud noise in another room that would
lead him away but thankfully blind Miki
shall not win this day I am here and I
am here to stay so why don't you go the
[ __ ] away okay so where did it go oh
these nights are long aren't they long
and hard I think in the demo it doesn't
contain all the nights that would be in
fact I see Freddy's I don't know what it
goes up to but I think it goes tonight
too
if I'm not mistaken I keep expecting him
to pop up why isn't he here yet
else would he be he's like no way unless
he's actually here and I'm just not
seeing oh this is the kernel randomly so
jump scare at me which would be very
dickish but hey this is a five nights at
Freddy's game so why not it actually is
it's pretty good I got to admit it's not
perfectly recreated but you know for a
guy that was just making it on his own
this like really it's not bad it's got
some good ambiance to it like I'm
actually checking the cameras and I
don't know if that's disadvantageous to
me yet but hey at least it keeps me busy
oh there he is okay so that's not too
near to me I think I'm right here but
hey mickey hey mickey panicky adharma
hey Mickey you're so fine you're so fine
you blow my mind hey mickey
hey your pants oh good okay other the
Disney World or Disneyland the other day
was with the grumps and uh I got this
ice cream that was literally put into
Mickey's pants it was a sink though so
it was a sink full of ice cream but also
is Mickey pants I don't know if that's
trying to say something about American
culture that has some deeper meaning but
I'd like to assume that it does Oh
given that I have nothing else to talk
about that's exactly what I'm gonna talk
I'm actually kind of on edge I'm
surprised because I didn't go into this
expecting all that much because you know
obviously it's not five that's ready now
I'm very used to Five Dock siffredi at
this point so I know a lot about how the
game works and whatnot but I'm on edge
because I don't know what to expect and
that's what I love out of horror games
like I honestly don't know if
something's gonna pop out of me
I don't know how I should react when
things happen my instincts are all in
tune with like music box crank it up
do it all that do their windows watch
for foxy these are the road what was
that that was a loud noise oh no oh the
game oh the games crashing though well
you gotta admit it's going to have bugs
let me try to get back to it I'll be
with you in a moment
damage Greg here hey uh so sorry again
for making you do this you are an intern
after all chat hang oh no again with
this god dammit the crash again ah I
wanted to work so badly
alright here we go again I'm going to be
very cautious about flipping through
cameras so that you guys guys and girls
can enjoy this to the fullest extent if
any of you guys out there know any good
Mickey creepypastas at Disney
creepypastas in general I would love to
read them right in the comments below so
that other people can check out the
creepiness of the Disney World I mean
there's a lot of fake news stories about
what goes on in Disney or maybe real who
knows
to be honest I don't know if I need to
check the other cameras that's what I'm
sue me like I don't know cuz if he comes
in here and then I shut off a camera I'm
good right at least that's what I suit I
just don't want to flip through too many
cameras in case of crash this game again
like if there's another night I want to
get to at least that so that I can
continue such that it is come out come
out wherever you are make he's gonna
find you whoa where was that
some freddy fazbear's poopy going on ah
maybe that was goofy no goofy ste
slumbering his silent slumber let's not
disturb but oh I forgot there was
another guy over here no he's okay no
Mickey yet I don't know what it wants
for me it's like the first time I play
the game all the interesting stuff
happened or at least the one interesting
stuff happened and then nothing else
really wonder what's going to happen
when goofy rears is ugly head probably
shouldn't call him ugly whoa whoa ha
shut up
don't jump out at me you dickbag don't
do that I'm ok I did it in time
I didn't know that he would stand over
there I thought he'd have one spot but
that's actually interesting because that
means there's more variation to this
game that I have previously thought I'm
gonna keep it on a different camera now
so that I can shut it off if need be I'm
almost at 5 a.m.
these nights are freaking long as Frick
sadden that's off I don't know if it's
permanently off and I don't know how
much that'll dissuade me from eating my
face cuz obviously you need to face whoa
there you cool it with your strange
mysterious moaning
I don't much appreciate it see this is
what I'm talking about this is the error
mystery that I have not experienced
before
hmm I sound like the bar owner from
Deadwood right now I'm truly channeling
my inner whatever his name was I love
that guy he was also in the rocks
Hercules movie not the other one that
was also bad but the newer one it wasn't
that good either but it wasn't that bad
that guy has an awesome voice and in
deadwood at the counter bar owner also
had an amazing voice I don't know what
it was about bar owners in that time
having great voices but also when I get
sick it's just like I get that bass who
all about that bass bout that bass about
that bass no treble now please for the
love of God don't crash cuz if you crash
I won't be able to show this to all the
lovely people out there I just need to
make it through this last hour so that I
can move my way to the second night if
there is one and then I can go home no
god damn it screw this god I did that as
quick as I could there was literally
nothing else I could have done what the
bull oh damn it damn this damn it to
hell
damn this this is obscenely hard
I'm surprised whoa Adam oh yeah
god damn you you are a finicky bastard I
don't know what it is about today that
he's decided to be so active it's the
first night why get a life get a day job
I also don't know I've
the guys aren't doing anything it's just
Mickey on the first night it'd be like
Freddie coming out you and Freud answer
Freddie it's disgraceful that the boss
must come out for some unless he isn't
the boss maybe Mickey isn't actually in
charge here maybe Mickey is actually the
slave that would be the most interesting
all right so Mickey's out of his cage oh
now Mickey's back in good for him
Thank You Mickey for not being such a
dick whoa hey who's standing up Anna
wake your nap time over already
Dora have a cough drop in my mouth my
throat is very sore from all this
talking I've been recording for like 30
minutes
and I expected this to be one and done
so what are you gonna do about your
newfound stance your new bold
perspective Mickey what are you going to
do with all this power you hold in your
heart can you even control it can you
control anything Mickey are you truly in
charge here are you just another servant
to the world of Disney all right I'll
play a game to the end I've seen your
sick and twisted world through you
decapitated Donald you decapitated goofy
and whoever's body sitting over there
behind the boxes charas having a bad day
but I'm not I won't be another one to be
subject to your mutilated properties I
am a survivor I am the king of five
nights at Freddy and when the king lays
down the law the law is my domain I hope
that sounded actually proper because I
don't know if he's actually threatened
come on Mickey show me that six yes I
did it I can't yell because my voice is
still a little raw Wow there is an eye
to shoe Nikes well that'll have to wait
until the next episode because I'm
actually all out of time so if there is
something here I can't do it
so thank you all so much for watching if
you actually do want to see Wow yeah
whatever so anyway that's all for now
thank you all so much for watching if
you really want me to play the next
night there might be some new surprises
in here you can play it for yourself
down in the description below but I mean
it's actually not a bad recreation of
five nights at Freddy's so if you want
to see it let me know if you want to
play it go right ahead there might be
more secrets in there there's that error
mystery a little bit of things that is
the unknown in the world and that's good
to see so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos if you haven't seen five nights
at Freddy's already and I bet you have
check it out over there in the
description below thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh